[موسيقى]
ببساطه
بابتسامه واثقه من حالها بحب احكي لكم انا
من ذوي الاعاقه
نحن لا نحتاج الى شهادات نحن نحتاج الى
الاثر الذي تتركه هذه الشهادات
بسيطه
الجامعي كيف ممكن يختار تخصص الجامعي لو
ان يتوجه هل يزور الجامعات هل يستشير
ابو امه
هل
يذهب لا طلب المساعده من مرشد ببساطه انا
اختيار تخصص الجامعي ما كان ايرادتي كان
بناء على ظروف محيطه به لانك تم تشخيصي
بشلل الاطفال منذ طفولته
تشلل الاطفال يعني بطئ بالحركه
متساوي الى الجميع
تخصص هندسه الحاسوب
اختيارته بناءا على مستقبلي هل ممكن حاله
الصحيه تتطور واستخدام كرسي المتحرك هل
ممكن اصاب بشلل تام وشلل وكامل
بيومها جميع البشر بشوفوا كلمه ناجح ناجح
بمعدل باهلك لدخول اي تخصص
ملموس تخصص ممكن الكل يطمحله
تخصص الكل ممكن يحط فيه امكانياته لحتى
يفوت وينقابل بهذه الكليه
ولكن انا في يومها
لوين انا رايحه لانه كان لاول مره في
حياتي بستخدم الحاسوب في مختبر الجامعه
بشكل فردي
لقيت نفسي امام جهاز
شايفه فيه مستقبلي الطريق الى المستقبل
البنت اليوم الوقفه قدامكم بتحكي بكل هذه
الثقه بالنفس والمثابره
ما اجت من فراغ شخصيتها اشتغلت حالها كثير
سهره الليالي بفضل دعم كثير اشخاص كثير
اشخاص
حربها كلمات تنمر جارحه ولكن كان انساني
من ذوي الاعاقه اكيد كانساني الي مشاعر
تتروح بين الحصان الفرح الدموع لما كنت
اسمع مثلا او اواجه مشكله شو ممكن كنت
اساوي الاعاقه ببساطه
ضوء القمر
من خلال سماع المتكرر لضوء القمر علمني
والهمني بجمله ان الذي لا يسمع سيضطر
العالم
من خلال دراستي بالجامعه
صار عندي حافز اتعرف على نفسي كانساني
عندها اعاقه
كيف انا ممكن اطول لحالي من خلال ابحاثي
وجدت انه في علماء من ذوي الاعاقه ومن
ضمنهم ستيفن هوكينج الذي علمني كيف استخدم
التكنولوجيا
وسخرها للتعامل مع احتياجات الخاصه
ستيفن هوكينج
اعاقه مثلي الهمني انه التكنولوجيا ممكن
كثير ستساعدني بحادث اكثر عرفت عن نظريات
العلميه والفلسفيه اكثر من ضمنها نظريه
الثقوب السوداء نظريه الثقوب السوداء
الهمتني لمقوله شخصيه
اننا كاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه وجميع
التحديات التي تمر بنا
والصعوبات التي نواجهها والاراده الكامنه
فينا والتي تحاربنا ما هي الا ثقوب سوداء
لن تقيفنا عن اطلاق طاقاتنا البشريه
والفكريه والروحيه لنمر الى عالم افضل
ومستقبل افضل
[تصفيق]
دائما كنت اسال نفسي ليش انا بالذات ليش
انا الوحيده بين زملائي
المعاقه او ليش الوحيد الانساني بين اخوتي
التي تمتلك اعاقه بين مجتمعي بين بيئه
المحيطه فيه ببساطه لما درست البرمجه
لما درست هندسه الحاسوب لما تعمقت في
البرمجه اكثر فهمت انا ليه ربنا اختارني
بنت من دوله
علمتني انني الاكثر القدر على التحمل
والاكثر قدره على الصبر ببساطه
البرمجه تحتاجه الى كثير من الجهد وحل
المشكله الكثير من الصبر على تدقيق في
الاخطاء الكثير من الصبر والتحمل
والمساواه في الزمان لفهم نقاط ضعف
تكنولوجيا ونقاط قوه التكنولوجيا
والمثابره على
ايجاد وتوضيح التحديات التي تطلق في ايه
من خلال العالم
صار عندي حلم كثير كبير وكبير بعيد
باخر ثانيه وفصل اللي بالجامعه اشتركت من
خلال الجامعه بمسابقه هذا المسابقه كانت
عالميه انا مو امنه انسانه مؤمنه ان
999 تجربه رح تفشل ولكن التجربه رقم الف
هي الناجحه بالتاكيد اشتريت بالمسابقه
وكان اسمها غير اسم جيهان
للاسف في المرحله الاولى انا فشلت انا
وفريقي بشلت صرت اسال نفسي شو الحكمه
والقدريه اللي خلتني افشل كان في يوم من
الايام بعد اسبوع بالدوره الثانيه ماراثون
فلسطين
من دوت الاعاقه مثلي شوفوا جيهان في صوره
ندى الصغيره مشاعرها نفس مشاعر نداء
تحدياتها نظرات الخوف في جيهان كانت عباره
عن نداء صغيره واقفه قدامها هون بالتحديد
اعطاني شعور دافع شغف بدي اعرف مين جيهان
انا شايفه نداء صغيره بتمشي على الارض
بطفله مستقبلها مجهول مثل ما كان مستقبل
نداء مجهول
قربت على الطفل
قضيت التحيه لامها تعرفت على امها بحكي
لها
بتعرفي انه البنت الي واقفه قدامك اليوم
كانت حالتها الصحيه اصعب بكثير من حاله
بنتك
بتعرفي انا في يوم من الايام ما كنت قادر
امسك القلم بتعرفي انه انا ما كنت قادره
امشي بشكل طبيعي كل ما امشي خطوتين اكا
امها
تحكي عن جد بتحكي عن جد بتحكي
وكانه اعطيتها دافع
انا اليوم
مهندسي وبقدر اعتبر حالي ناجحه انا اليوم
طالبي وانا اليوم مجتمعي بشوفوني كشخصيه
مؤثره انتصرت على الاعاقه
من فرحه الام وكاي ام في العالم
بس بطريقه صوت غير مسموع بنتي راح تشفى
بنتي راحت تصير في يوم من الايام
بالمناسبه هذه الطفله جيهان هذه صورتي
الشخصيه وانا مع جيهان قدام
جيهان ما كانت مجرد طفلي بالنسبه لي كانت
طريق اللي عرفت من وين ابدا لمستقبلي رجعت
على سكن الجامعي
استخدمت جوجل بحث عن اسم جيهان اسم جيهان
يعني العالم وباجمعه هنا بالتحديد فهمت
ليه
القدره والحكمه لماذا انا فشلت اول مره من
اسم جيهان امنت ان فكرتي يجب ان تلف
العالم وتخدم العالم باجمعه من خلال خدمه
مليون شخص من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه في
القطاع الصحي
دائما بصمه لما بشعر بس
التوتر الاوضاع بالالهام احيانا بالنقد
بصمه وبدور على
الحكم من الاشياء
الحكم من الاحداث الحكم من المواقف
الاعاقه علمتني
ابحث دائما عن الحكمه لانه الحكمه هي
بتقودنا الى المستقبل بدون الحكمه لا يمكن
للانسان ان يتقدم الى طريق عارف رؤيته
وبعده المكان والزماني
[تصفيق]
بعد ما شفت اسم جيهان فهمت الحكمه
ولكن عندي سؤال مهم مين مين اهم دكتور
بالعالم
دكتور بالعالم انت احكي لي مين اهم دكتور
بالعالم من اهم دكتور بالعالم
الام هي اهم دكتور بالعالم لانها بتعرف
متطلبات الشخص ذوي الاعاقه سواء كان حزين
سواء كان مريض سواء ارتفع درجه حرارته
فامي شفت فيي بنت عارفه وين رايحه
لمستقبلها ما حطمتني هون لازم نعرف شخص
شيء مهم كثير
ومبدا مهم كثير
للعائله لا الاهل للمجتمع للجامعه لايئه
تعليميه ومجتماعيه
ان اعاقه اي انسان ليس بارادته وليس
اختياري ولكن تمكينه
وجعل المجتمع ظروف به
ومواءمته هو محد قراره هو محظو اختياره
الشخصي
في المرحله الثانيه والمرحله الاقليميه تم
اختياري من قبل المسابقه ونفسه على
المستوى الثاني بفضل هذا الالهام الجيهان
لانني امنت ورايت ان كل طفل من ذوي
الاعاقه هو صوره نداء الشخصيه التي يجب ان
تحظى بمساعدته مثل ما ساعدني الاخرين
فهمت ان هذه الحكمه ان الرساله اصبحت ليست
مجرد طالبه ليست مجرد انسان انعاقتها ليست
مجرد مهندسه ولكن فهمت انني مختاره لخدمه
الاشخاص من ذوي الاعاقه
في المرحله الثانيه انا وفريقي في المرحله
الثانيه كنا عارفين انه احنا مش راح نفوز
ولكن لسبب وحيد انا تبعت المنافسه لحتى
اقدر افهم نقاط ضعفنا في المجتمع المحلي
نقاط قوتنا في المجتمع ليه انا الجامعات
الاخرى
انا نجحت وتمكنت وصلت من تحقيق اهداف
صغيره الي ولكن الحلم الكبير لسه ما صار
الحلم الكبير اني الف العالم وامسك كل طفل
من ذوي الاعاقه او بنت من ذوي الاعاقه
وامكنهم لحتى في يوم من الايام تشوفه
اشخاص واقفين بالمئات على مسارح عالميه
بيحكي بكل فخر وبكل اعتزاز بنفسي انا
انسان كنت في يوم من ذوي الاعاقه الاعاقه
لم تعلمني فقط الاستسلام الاعاقه علمتني
كثير من الاشياء الصبر الالهام فهم الحكم
الربانيه
تعلمتني حل المشكله علمتني المرونه في
العمل علمتني ايضا كيفيه توصيل صوتي
الداخلي والتعامل مع الاصوات الخارجيه من
حولك لتحويل رسالات الداخليه الى رسائل
عالميه
ايضا الاعاقه لم تعلمنا وحدي علمت كل شخص
عرف هذه
الفتاه المثابره التي وقفت امامكم علمتهم
كيف يمكن ان نبدا من الصفر كيف يمكن ان
نتحدى الامور
الداخله في ثقوب السوداء الجدران المحيطه
بنا
علمتنا وتعلم الاخرين تقبل الاخرين التوقف
عن التنمر
انا انتصرت على اعاقتي بفضل امي لانها
وجدت امه مثقفه وهنا يجب دائما ان نتعامل
مع الثقافه قبل ان نتعامل مع شخص انه مجرد
له اعاقه لنفهم ثقافته لنفهم بيئته
احتياجاته الخاصه
امكانيهاته وبفضل يا جامعيه حاضنه دعمتني
فهمت احتياجاته
ورات في اختلاف كبير اختلاف بشري ممكن
يضيف لهذا المجتمع من الطلاب وتميز
الجامعات الاخرى وايضا
انتصرت على الاعاقه بفضل المواقف السلبيه
نعم
المواقف السلبيه
اكثر ما جعلني انتصر على الاعاقه هي
عندما قالت هذه المعلمه لوالدتي في يوم
الايام وكانت نيتها لا تقصد شيئا سوا نقل
الواقع البيئي التعليمي للطفل لولي امره
بصوره شفافه جدا قالت لامي ببساطه بنتك ما
راح تقدر تمسك القلم في يوم من الايام
بنتك ما راح تصير مثل اختها بنتك ما راح
تصير في يوم من الايام توصل للجامعه بس
البنت اللي انحكالها في يوم من الايام ما
راح تقدر تمشي كل القلم لانها صنفوها من
شخص ذوي الاعاقه قدر التحميل مايكات
عالميه وتوصل رسالتها
وبفضل مبدا اؤمن به بشده هل تعتقدون ان
المواقف السلبيه كلمات التنمر والتجريح
من حاول ايقافي واذيه سواء النفسيه
والجسديه هل تعتقدون انه زرع في حقدا او
كرها لا والله
باجعلني انتصر اكثر لانني اؤمن وعلى ايمان
تام بمبدا من حياتي انها المراه الوحيده
التي لا يمكن هزيمتها في هذا العالم هي
المراه المحبه
لذا ادعو
كل من تواجد هنا ومن كل سيسمعني في يوم من
الايام لا تحقد لا تكره ولكن غير الهم
اجعل الشرف
يملا هذا المكان بالنهايه اود شكر كل من
يؤمن بان رحله كل معاق وشخص من ذوي
الاعاقه واجهه تحديا في يوم من الايام في
رحلته شخصيه والعلميه والتعليميه او ايا
كان من رحلات حياته
شكرا له لانه يؤمن بان كتابه
كان كتابه رحله الكفاح لاي شخص عنده
الاعاقه هي اشبه بكتابه سيره ذاتيه مطبوعه
للانسانيه عنوانها الحب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]